so you know the chicken sandwich right
it's very it's really fire obviously but
there are two main options one is
Chick-fil-A and one is uh Popeyes yeah
if you pick Popeyes move to the
left-hand side and if you like
Chick-fil-A maybe move the right hand
side
hi I'm Kat Arielle I'm 24 years old hi
I'm Isabella and I'm 24 years old I'm
Alexander I'm 25 years old hi I'm ronia
and I'm 24 years old hi I'm Pierre and
I'm 19 years old hi I'm Rebecca and I'm
19 years old hi I'm jazlyn and I'm 20
years old I was just purely trying to go
off of voice initially I just wanted to
sort it as like black and then everyone
else so I think the girl to my left has
to go more towards the left for darker I
hear an accent so I think that it's like
Middle Eastern like Indian possibly so
we can put her at number four if you
want just write dab in the middle yeah
she could go four
the way you speak reminds me of
something like aave kind of sound
patterns that we see in linguistics so I
feel like you could be darker so I don't
know if that's you just stay where you
are or if you have to move or anything I
also do have like a lot of a b like in
my dialogue so it's like I'm not gonna
lie I was kind of expecting it Pierre I
believe he has a very French sounding
name I would say he should switch a spot
with me
[Music]
remind me of your name the one with the
accent that was to my right ronia I am
very familiar with a lot of people with
a similar accent and the area is diverse
for sure but I'm sensing that she might
be a little lighter skin actually so
yeah maybe once one over
I had a little icebreaking question
um how many of us here tan easily I do I
tan various I do I think that's a great
question that was a great question
someone said they didn't can easily yeah
the girl to my left I'm me too yeah
whoever said they don't tan easily
should go on the Lighter Side well I'm
noticing now a little bit this may be
totally off but I detect a little bit of
Latin in your accent I might be totally
wrong though I agree that there's a
definitely an accent I just can't
pinpoint exactly where it's from how far
do you think that she should move up
maybe not at the very end I definitely
somewhere in the middle yeah I'd say
like maybe maybe four it's hard it's
hard to force the magic number yeah or
it could be good
[Music]
so you know the chicken sandwich right
it's very it's really fire obviously but
there are two main options one is
Chick-fil-A and one is uh Popeyes yeah
if you pick Popeyes move to the
left-hand side and if you like
Chick-fil-A maybe move to the right hand
side
what spot are you on I'm definitely more
on the uh pop by his side I think
Alexander should come to the left yeah
it's darker yeah no he needs to go to
the right I mean based on his own
analysis I suppose he should go to the
left because he said if Chick-fil-A go
to the right
so if he's Popeyes then he should go to
them how many spaces just switch with
cat I guess I was just curious if we're
all canceled or not because this
conversation be very ignorant and I was
debating on even like trying to ask
anything because it's so hard to like
base things off of just like questions I
try to make it kind of funny be like
well if you like Chick-fil-A move here
Popeyes move here where's everybody from
England L.A Los Angeles
Dubai
oh wow that's amazing I'm from Long
Beach Los Angeles I'm from La South La
specifically where's your accent from my
accent I thought it was American it
sounds a little bit there's a twinge
I worked on it for seven years like
South African or something yeah that
definitely would work without a doubt
well she needs to be where I'm at I
think I disagree I think she should be
more to the right honestly if we're
thinking South Africa because it's a
very diverse country I think she should
move one one side to the right honestly
I think I should stick her place
when you grew up was family like a big
thing for you guys or was it more
everybody was more individualistic we're
really really family oriented and I grew
up doing like everything with them I
feel like growing up in Utah it's a very
like
conventional
familial place because of the culture I
grew up with both my parents in the
household and I'm pretty much do
everything for them family is very
important to me but I grew up with a
single mom Ronnie did that change
anything for you I mean the single mom
comment was interesting but it's hard to
say exactly what evokes because
obviously The Stereotype is there are
more broken families stereotypically in
Darker skin communities but there's also
plenty of
um broken homes in like lighter skin
communities I think just based on what
you said right now and that you pointed
out that I think you have to be a little
more on my left yes I was just gonna say
that as well I feel like Ronnie you
might want to move down like two maybe
it's Tuesday is right now yeah okay when
did you guys first become aware of the
differences in skin tone my family's
like pretty liberal so we're very I'm
living in such a conservative State I I
feel like I was taught very early on or
like learning about the differences and
how we're treated and stuff pretty young
because my family is pretty passionate
about equality she definitely needs that
spot
let's all agree absolutely yeah she
belongs there for sure yeah the
relationship with my skin tone to like
myself personally I never felt insecure
about it but I definitely felt I think
it's like exhaustion I don't want to
have to explain who my parents are like
to like random strangers everything's
always racial all the time like when it
comes to me and that's it's just it's
really exhausting I realized that pretty
young I come from a country where
colorism is still existent to this day
growing up it was the media
representation that really made me feel
like I'm not the standard so we might
have to yeah
next to me properly or something like
that let's go and talk about what
everyone's hair type is I have curly
hair I have straight hair I have baby
hair I have wavy curly hair curly hair
straight hair mine's also wavy to curly
Pierre you kind of give up so you play
soccer and you're from Long Beach oh you
give up Latino Vibes bro I know
because the name was throwing me off
wait what's your favorite team here uh
Real Madrid Latino
Pierre and Alex should switch I'm
getting I'm getting stronger man and
then turn left around like no one's
business the most what was everyone's
experiences and where they grew up so
like how did everyone like
proceed like what was it like
interacting with others I look very
different for most people I get a lot of
questions like oh what's your ethnicity
um where are you from oh is that your
mom or was that your dad right you
belong here
I think my circumstances are pretty
unique growing up it was constantly
mentioned my skin tone and what I looked
like and yeah as a big topic of
conversation for sure do you have
freckles yes I do maybe she's
like strawberry blonde or yeah I have
like an image of her in my head and
she's like redhead yeah I mean I don't
know why yeah just the voice matches so
well yeah you give off redhead with like
a bunch of freckles I don't know anyone
else want to talk about their
experiences there is a lot of diversity
where I'm from but for the most part I
didn't really that there was nothing
extra interesting about
my experience where I grew up what city
are you from London what part
Southeast I think she's got to move to
the left yeah I think so too I forgot I
think I've heard that South London is
kind of like more diverse diverse yeah
yeah I think she moves to three I think
she'll be at three honestly I think she
should switch here
do you feel like your ethnicity like
historically has faced
yeah challenges yes yeah like oppression
maybe not in the past but definitely now
that makes sense like it definitely
always
if they were here oh that makes me want
to move you a little to the right yeah I
think she needs it would just switch to
the two it's amazing yeah let's have
everyone else finish the question that
was originally asked no yes uh somewhat
yeah yeah
yes uh I think I'd move cat up one cat
and Pierre I don't I don't know I think
they're good where they are personally
but if you guys think that I'm telling
you the girl from the UK man I feel like
yeah do you want to pierce too high up
y'all you guys feel like we really like
me I like that wait you wanted uh Ronnie
to move right did we ever move her yes
let's trust his intuition I like it yeah
go with what he's saying number two
Ronnie
we are ready to do the reveal
if everyone wants to take their
blindfolds off go ahead
oh oh it is bright oh wow cool
oh
oh right I was literally that's what I
said too
too yeah I do Rebecca I knew it see you
got it I was honestly expecting to see
more darker skinned people but surprise
surprise like I was on second it was
cool to see all these different
backgrounds as well everyone was very
diverse do you guys want to now
rearrange yourselves based on your
actual skin tone
sure if yeah I was right
I'm like deciding Who's the artist here
I would definitely if I hadn't laid out
yesterday I would definitely be probably
maybe but right now probably you yeah
what about you two are you
um I think you're lighter than him oh
right or no maybe a little bit a little
bit Yeah tiny bit
I think we did pretty well considering
we couldn't see anyone
does everyone want to go down the line
and say what their ethnicity is I'm
afro-latina so my parents are from
Guatemala but my mom is black I'm
Scottish in English originally but both
my parents have adoption on their side
so I don't know I'll never know but
white for sure I'm half asian half
Latina half white half Middle Eastern
I'm Indian
my dad's Japanese mom's African-American
Nigerian
so I grew up in South La so if you were
in Latino you were black you're Latino
um and I have a I have a skin condition
so I have albinism and so I was always
like the lightest everywhere and people
were just like oh what are you even
outside of my own Community it's like
what are you because I'm not like
pigmented at all beautiful that's what
you are thank you thank you when I was
in sixth grade the gingers have no souls
thing came out oh so yeah I was always
definitely like I wasn't necessarily
bullied but being a Ginger was a topic
of conversation like growing up for sure
systematically obviously I was not
impacted because as a white person
unfortunately in America that's kind of
the way it goes so like I definitely was
impacted but not to the extent that I
could have been you know just social
media yeah exactly I was born in India
but I moved to the UAE like right after
and colorism like I said is really
persistent in my country
um so I'm not on the like darkest end of
the Spectrum in my country but I'm like
middle toned so bleaching is huge wait
bleaching is huge they have like lotion
and I used to use that like just like
random motion yeah not knowing anything
like we have Bollywood right and you see
all these actresses they're mostly
light-skinned so when you see like
lighter skin people like being glorified
you automatically start to think you're
not yeah yeah for sure so for me it's
very interesting because I moved around
a lot growing up in La I knew I was
different but it wasn't didn't really
affect me all that much
um I just knew I had a black mom and an
Asian Dad but when I moved to Texas when
I was in the South it was the first time
it's called like the n-word or like
exactly yeah
but like I said you know I just accept
it and there were definitely pros and
cons now I look I have a really
interesting experience with race because
I mean I did notice some things I was
like oh my gosh all the boys in school
like the like lighter girls wow that's
like interesting to kind of push it
bluntly it was like I moved to America
and was told to feel oppressed and again
it's like it wasn't white people telling
me all of these things it was black
people 10 me all of these things and
that was really interesting and I felt
really like why do you guys want me to
fail or why do you guys want me to think
from a position of failure and then
something that was interesting is I
sound white I met a guy once and he came
up to me and he was like oh I didn't
expect you to sound like that and I was
like oh well you know your race is the
least interesting thing about you and a
lot of your experience with your race
will be defined by the culture you are
surrounded by as opposed to the actual
color of your skin you're beautiful no
matter what you look like for sure I
feel like it's really important to
regard like self-worth off of character
rather than physical appearance overall
what's inside matters way more so just
be a good person don't be afraid to like
accept your culture and just like be
proud of your background because I know
that it's hard when you're a minority in
a person of color in America so I think
that we should just like be proud of our
background